time for the long gene chrono scope a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the laun gene which nor
what's company's maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the
launching chrono scope Larry Ellis sir
from the CBS television news staff and
kenneth crawford national affairs editor
of newsweek magazine our distinguished
guest for this evening is the honorable
herman talmadge governor of georgia
governor Talmadge the economic situation
I guess is just about the most important
subject in the country these days I'd
like to ask you how is business down in
Georgia well on the whole it's held up
remarkably well Larry but farm prices as
you know have been going down for
approximately 18 months in Georgia with
all of its great industrial expansion is
still largely an agricultural state our
farmers on parent too well at the moment
they're concerned because if farm prices
had been going down about 18 months
everything that buy has either been
going up or remaining at high levels so
they have been caught in a price-squeeze
it's concerned them a great deal
governor President Eisenhower apparently
was quite popular in your state in the
last election as the economic slump
affected that where the president was
relatively popular can but you must
remember that Georgia gave the
Democratic Party and the Democratic
nominee governor Stevenson the greatest
percentage wise majority of any state in
the Union the relatively large vote that
President Eisenhower polled in Georgia
was due largely to his personal
popularity the respect and the
confidence that people had in President
Eisenhower second it was a good many of
them in Georgia this
with President Truman now I would not
think that the Republican Party in
Georgia is anything like is popular as
President Eisenhower and if the
elections for Congress were held at the
present time Republican candidates in
Georgia would not poll half as many
votes as President Eisenhower polled in
the last presidential election
Oh governor oh you uh Georgia Democrats
feel as the head of the Democratic Party
now is it
governor Adlai Stevenson well of course
Harry Truman we recognize governor Adlai
Stevenson as the titular head of the
Democratic Party since it was he who
carried the Democratic standard in the
last presidential election 1952 the
Georgians looked to their United States
senators that congressman and to their
Democratic governor to form policy in
our state rather than to the titular
head of the National Democratic Party do
you think that Senator Russell's name
would be presented again at the next
Democratic convention as it wasn't the
last I don't know whether it will be
presented again a nod I presume that
fact would be determined by Senator
Russell's wishes if he desires to do so
certainly Georgians will support him as
loyally and the next Democratic
convention is they have unless - well
governor who do you Democrats feel
controls the Democratic Party now the
industrial north or the more
conservative south well I wouldn't say
that either element entirely controls it
now prior to the last day to the last
convention when they were passing the
so-called moody resolution the
Democratic convention in 52 it was
pretty apparent that the left-wing
elements of the industrial east were in
the ascendancy of the party at that
particular time but before that
Democratic convention adjourned reason
had reasserted itself somewhat and some
of those who had rammed through some of
those stringent restrictions had to eat
crow and the southerners and the
conservatives were in the ascendancy of
the party and regain control prior to
its
convention prior to its agenda well
speaking about that civil rights
platform the Supreme Court is here to
make a decision pretty soon Sarah on the
segregation in the schools now how do
you George and thinks that decision is
gonna go well anticipating what the
Supreme Court will do all you can do
Larry is follow legal precedents that
have existed for a great number of years
now we know that the Supreme Court of
the United States the last eighty eight
years has been making decisions relative
to segregation in the common schools
those decisions have all been the same
they've been written by Justice Brandeis
Chief Justice Hughes William Howard Taft
just to storm all of the legal Giants of
American jurisprudence without exception
they have held a matter of segregation
in the common schools of our state as a
matter that addresses itself to each
state and not to the federal government
nowhere in the federal constitution is
the word schools or education or
anything of that kind mention
Constitution hasn't changed the laws
have not changed sometimes the political
complexion of a court does change
sometimes it may be swayed by political
pressures or sometimes by sociological
opinions but if they follow the law is
all lawyers understanding they will
uphold the present method which is
separate but equal schools and each
state themselves may determine whether
they want to maintain and preserve
segregation or whether they want to
change governor assuming however that
this decision does go against you what
plans have you well we have made any
particular plans as yet because we don't
know what the decision will be but we
have tried to be forearmed the General
Assembly of Georgia authorized a study
commissioned at its last session of the
General Assembly that's composed of
approximately 21 ladies and gentlemen of
which I am chairman a good many of the
constitutional officers of the state
government are ex officio members and I
as chairman of the Commission have
appointed the number of outstanding
leaders in all phases of activity in our
state we will study any decision of the
Supreme Court make recommendations to
the General Assembly as to what court
the course of action it should follow
then in addition to that the last
session of the General Assembly
submitted a constitutional amendment the
people of our state for their approval
or rejection which will enable the
General Assembly in its discretion and
in its wisdom utilize tax forms for the
payment of tuition fees to private
institutions if that becomes necessary
well that is gonna be a very difficult
system as setup I suppose it's gonna be
very expensive sir anything the Supreme
Court does to thought or change our
present system of state control of our
educational systems will be the most
difficult thing that we in the southern
states have had to approach or deal with
since the war between states will affect
something like 12 million schoolchildren
about 17 states in the District of
Columbia now tremendous number actually
17 states have mandatory segregation
four states have permissive segregation
but at one time the overwhelming
majority of the states in the Union had
segregation now the people of white
people in the south and also the Negroes
in the south want it left alone just
like it is gonna agitate us white and
colored won't change governor this means
in effect that your state would set up a
private school system I don't think is
in a doubt but what my state would do so
if they had to to maintain segregation
we intend to maintain separate schools
in Georgia one way or another come what
made you a lot of people that aren't
familiar with it don't realize how
far-reaching or deep seeded that is for
both races white and colored now about
the nearest comparison that I can
possibly think of it's moment if the
Supreme Court of the United States
suddenly handed down a decision that you
could no longer worship your God and
these United States is you saw fit you
can imagine the consternation okay
the turmoil the excitement that that
would create any decision to outlaw
segregation in the common schools and
the southern states would amount to
about the same thing in our area well
governor does that mean if you're gonna
may set up private schools and state
funds that no matter how the decision
goes the Negroes are gonna benefit
through better schools and hikes or
advanced education actually the
negatives are already benefiting through
finding schools in Georgia last several
years we've been building fine schools
in the university system and in the
common schools we spend 53 cents out of
every tax dollar collected in Georgia
for public education that is the highest
percentage of any state in the Union the
next highest percentage is our sister
state of South Carolina that spends 48
cents out of every dollar for common
school education we are in Georgia at
the present time building 1036 new
school buildings in every county in the
state for both white and colored
students absolutely without any
distinction whatsoever it involves
12,000 new classrooms it's the most
gigantic construction program undertaken
in the history of my state well governor
I know the local custom and tradition
are against racial mingling but how do
you think this whole problem is gonna be
solved in the future well it'll have to
be solved in the future just as it has
been solved in past by each state
controlling state matters and the
federal government handling federal
problems and leaving local matters long
because if we had to set up a federal
bureaucracy that tries to regulate the
lives and social customs and feelings
and one thing in another of all of its
citizens
it will mean our Republican form of
government as we know it today will be
destroyed the federal government next
we'll be having thought police and
people to go around and examine you to
see if you have any prejudices against
red-headed people or blue-eyed people or
freckle-faced people and we find
ourselves getting into the realm of the
redic
ulis when we try to deal with matters
that aren't authorized by the Federal
Constitution the governor I'd like to
ask you the final question something
about the industrial situation in the
south now this lot of factories are
moving down there from the north and
furthermore a lot of new factories are
opening up narrator you think this is
going to give the South a lot more
political power in the future well I
wouldn't say necessarily political Paulo
Larry but it will mean for more economic
ability for our own local citizens we're
proud of the industrial progress that we
have made in my state last year Georgia
received 270 new industries located in
Georgia and the increased payrolls of
those industries in 1 year long amount
to between 40 and 50 millions of dollars
now lots of those industries were
developed by local people with local
capital we don't offer any inducement to
any industries located in Georgia we
want them to become citizens help them
develop I'll help us develop our state
we're all from no advantages whatsoever
we don't give to other Georgia citizens
thank you very much governor proud to
have you tonight thank you it's a
pleasure to be with you the opinions
expressed on the lawn gene Khanna scope
were those of the speakers the editorial
board for this edition of the launching
Cronus cope was Larry Lucerne and
Kenneth Crawford our distinguished
guests was the honorable Herman Talmadge
governor of Georgia